so you're
one of the most successful and brilliant
people the world has ever seen so you're
the good person to ask
uh for advice you know there's a lot of
young people that look up to you
god bless their souls and hearts made
the right choice
what advice would you give to a young
person maybe to yourself
to a young version of yourself you know
just how to live a successful
a good life be doggedly you
i think uh the magic happens when you
are stubbornly doggedly you and you meet
other people who are doing the same and
um the real magic of life the real true
currency and this ephemeral life is sort
of the
communication that happens between
people
uh that's the real currency friendships
love it's it's cliche but it's a
i think the meaning of life is to
experience
to experience love and uh i think people
often mistake maybe it's because of
hollywood films and things like that
that love is a feeling but it's not it's
an
action so uh that took me a while to
learn and i think that's why i've made
decisions since that i think have been
good for me and healthy for me
love is an action uh people can say
things you can
feel things um that doesn't mean they're
necessarily real it's all chemical
reactions
it's all tied to our immaturity
and psychological issues and uh survival
but action when so when you do things
when you
act out of love and you that's
that's what it's about is there uh times
when you're younger where you were kind
of
this dishonest with who you are to
yourself
yeah in terms of like what what kind of
things did you have to do to
to shake yourself up and be like okay i
thought
um i thought i'm going to be a scientist
but instead i i
realize i'm going to do this yeah my
parents make funny yeah my
comedy is a hard thing to explain to uh
you know an immigrant mother who came
here
and under nazi occupied crete and became
a human rights lawyer and lawyer and
my brother's a lawyer my father was a
lawyer you know clawed his way up his
dad was a
was a um senior disappointment i'm the
black sheep yeah my brother went to
oxford georgetown law
brown you know has masters and
you know law degrees my mother has
followed four law degrees uh
you know uh she was on the human rights
commission new york up for a judgeship
under dinkins
um wrote a you know uh she was the
editor of unitard
she she wrote a seminal piece on the
human rights of children for the united
nations
um and uh yeah i was a comedian i was
always a [ __ ] up
and uh the thing that i was best at the
only thing i was ever decent at was just
like
making people laugh i don't know why i
don't know where that comes from
but uh was there a question or did was
there a moment where you decided this is
what i'm gonna do
there was a moment after i graduated
college yeah but i was thinking about
all types of stuff that
other people imposed on me and um i was
honest with myself and uh once i figured
out it was an actual career path
i wasn't even aware back then the
internet wasn't huge you know in late 99
2000 it wasn't big yet so i didn't i
thought robin williams was just like an
actor i didn't know there was comedy
clubs and all
so once i learned that i was just like i
tried it i
suffered from massive anxiety i remember
the first time i did comedy my arms went
numb i started having a massive panic
attack
i have my first set i can show it to you
it's like i suggest i just
video yeah video guys thank you thank
you thank you and the reason why i kept
saying thank you because i forgot my old
jokes i was so scared
and then they laughed because of the
amount of times i said thank you and
then once they laughed
i was i remembered the whole thing and i
did the five minutes and i remember
getting off
and for a person who never felt like he
had a place anywhere nothing ever felt
right
that felt like okay i found it this is
what i'm supposed to do
this is it it was the only time in my
life i felt that i haven't felt it since
never felt it before so that's the only
thing i can do
and um yeah i had that you know it's
funny because there's uh i've
similar experience like immigrant family
and the world tells you to do certain
things
and you think that's right but but then
you put yourself in situations by luck
probably
where it's like oh this this this
this feels right i don't know what this
means but this feels right
i think the the the biggest moment like
that for me was
uh i don't know what to make of it
exactly but
when i met spot the robot the legged
robot
it was like five years ago it felt like
this there the depth of fascinating
ideas
that are yet to be explored with this
thing this felt like a journey it was
like a door that opened
and i was like i don't want to be a
professor
at that point i realized i don't want to
do sort of generic stuff i want to do
something crazy
i want to do something big that's the
reason i stepped away from mit that's
the reason
i have this burning desire to do a
startup that's the reason i came to
austin
yeah i don't know what the hell it all
means but you just kind of follow that
that's awesome
that sounds like you're following what's
dog of the you and also i think
uh just to just to piggyback off it i
think that means
but no matter what it is because i think
our uh the american dream is sold like
hey if you're not
beyonce or if you're not famous you're
not worth it i
hate that and that's what i love so much
about certain countries like sweden it's
a
it's like um where everyone has health
care and stuff like that because
everyone's a little
is valued more it's like whatever if you
want to be a doormat do it like
it's all the same prince was not happy
there's no
just because you're rich or famous
you're still the same guy
with your possessions are a lot little
you know it's like
i i have met some doorman i have met
some tax covers that
i a lot of you not are more fascinating
i have comedians are horrible people
i want to get away from all that i have
very few friends
paul versi tim dillon who are comedians
because they're awful awful people
some of the people who you know the most
who are the most famous
are not who they say they are usually
that's the case they're putting on that
public facade because they're [ __ ]
sociopaths
yeah they're horrible people and some of
the most beautiful people i've met and
the most interesting people
i've met have regular jobs there's no
shame in
any [ __ ] job we don't all have to be
rappers
with like rims it's just a weird thing
yeah famous
fame is a drug and yeah comedians i
agree with you
there's some part of me that knows that
there'll be a moment in my life when i'm
standing there
with like a sword or a knife in my
stomach
and looking at tim dillon's smiling face
saying uh uh you shouldn't have trusted
me
you stupid [ __ ] so on that note
you honest i've been a huge fan of yours
i love what you're doing with long days
now your new podcast and um i obviously
love all the stuff you've done before
with history hyenas the chemistry
the the chemistry you have with yourself
is also fun to watch so man i'm a huge
fan it's a huge honor that you come down
here
thanks so much for talking today it
means so much to me to hear you say that
i really appreciate i'm a big fan of
yours and
have meown's been amazing and just thank
you man thank you for uh having me on
and
people if they want to watch my special
it's called blowing the light it's on
youtube and please come listen to long
days of the podcast
let's go eat some barbecue let's do it
you